um I was gonna ask you like uh so this
complex list comes out right okay uh
this is this is the headline okay no I'm
just curious because like I feel like
you're very like to like you I I mean
I'll be honest with you I feel like
you're the premier freestyle platform
now like I feel like you you guys what
you guys are doing is more important
than what the leakers do
um Flex is flex you know so Flex is
gonna get like yeah he Legend regardless
the Conway [__] that just happened was
crazy like I mean I still watched the
Black Thought one like once a week if
the Meek Mill ones are obviously Meek
Mill and the Tory Lanez ones I always
watch
um but I was gonna say for you like you
know we do we do freestyles here we drop
like two two probably one or two a week
it just depends on what happens here but
like you guys have really dug your heels
into the freestyle Lane and it's it's
been dope to see because I feel like
like you said like being in New York
there is like you can't you can't just
be anybody and go see Flex you know what
I'm saying yeah like you gotta have a
certain It's gotta make sense for him
right you know what I mean for you
you're giving people platforms that you
just believe in or that you're like hey
I think this person's dope I think more
people should have eyes on these on this
person absolutely
um so do you when you see like a list
like that come out do you feel like you
deserve more acknowledgment when it
comes to certain [__] like that or you I
mean you're still like a relatively new
platform but like what are your thoughts
on that kind of [__] I mean obviously
like you know
I'm like
first of all thank you for the for the
for the kind words and like also kind of
just going off what you said about
giving people a chance like the one
thing I want to say about on the radar
is I like the reason why on the radar is
what it is is because my goal for it is
to be able for you to have a Meek Mill
or a little baby on there but then also
a little homie from down the block right
you know I mean because I feel like
there's no place where you can marry all
those things into one place that's just
about the culture about hip-hop about
music in general right
um but when I see things like that like
of course like I'm like man like you
know I was bummed out about it but like
I've been the underdog for so long in my
life and in my career that like it
doesn't faze me because I know you know
the numbers like like I don't like to be
the person like look at the numbers but
the numbers are there you feel me like
we're doing things that hasn't really
been seen in a long time and hasn't you
know there is no platform since like I
feel like like a rap city that or like
106 and Park that's or TRL that's really
kind of brought like the up and coming
and like the who's hot at the same time
right the fact that I can go on my show
and like broke from down the block was
there and as he's walking out analy
Chapa is walking in like that's fire
right you know what I'm saying like
nobody's doing something like that or
like sexy Reds walking walking in as
like this up-and-coming R B singer from
jerseys is is leaving like that's dope
so of course like I see that on my damn
like this is crazy like I feel like we
deserve the recognition it was funny
because when that list came out
um that same night I was at like this
DeVito uh event at like Legos and uh and
like then they complex posted like the
up next like list thing they're like oh
hip-hop's next like whatever I forgot
what they called it but it was just like
it was just like a social post and it
was like me Hakeem from ogm
um don't call me white girl
I'm trying to think well there are a few
other people on that list but I'm like
all right so I'm a social post you know
what I'm saying but I appreciate all the
recognition regardless because I know
that like it's gonna be there right one
way or another but also like I just be
getting tired of the list too also this
[__] doesn't really matter it doesn't
like help it's like like you said check
to check the scoreboard you know what
I'm saying like yeah so like like I had
people hitting me like and I genuinely
just didn't care yeah how did you feel
about that I didn't give a [__] bro like
I really didn't expect to be on the list
like we're over here in La we are very
independent operation
I don't care about none of that [__] bro
like they try to uh get me to like be
angry on so whose show was on when they
asked me about it
t-real [__] oh tea rose
I just did I just like I have no emotion
man like my whole thing towards it is
like you know at the end of the day like
I'm doing me if people want to recognize
it it's cool if not
we're gonna be all right like yeah
that's how I feel shit's moving yeah we
good because I feel like it's just like
you know people love making these lists
right and also I it's a buy it's also
that's why I surprised you in because I
mean listen complex the East Coast buys
place right so I was really thinking
like how's the [__] going on over
there thing like you've had more moments
than a lot of these [__] right
saying like and you do it with the high
integrity you know what I mean yeah and
complex throwing up [__] you know
yeah complex sodas has shown us mad love
like we just had two freestyles on like
the top 25 verses of the year so far
um and they've done like other stuff
with me before so but I didn't feel no
way because of that like I wasn't I
didn't hit my man's at complex like yo
bro why you ain't put me on I would
never do that because I don't I don't
think that's a you know that's an
Integrity thing like I would never
handle business like that or come out my
neck at someone like that because that's
not how I am but you know at the end
days like you know you still are
disappointed you're like damn I wish I
could have been recognized by this but
it's like it's cool because I just kind
of turn all that fuel into motivation
like whenever they told me oh like you
know you won't be able to have this this
artist all right cool I'll see you in a
year right and like you know then we
then they end up coming back around
anyway because now they're like okay
cool like you know we'll have an artist
who comes on the show and we'll do an
interview they're like I don't know if I
want a freestyle and I'm like I I'll see
you and I'll see you in six months and
then six months later yo is it hard
because you you'll get freestyles from
artists who traditionally don't do
freestyles right yeah so do they go
there knowing they're gonna freestyle
because a lot of times we'll run into
that where like somebody will come to LA
and they'll have like their La leaker
[__] ready yeah and obviously that well
I'm valet leakers ain't a thing anymore
y'all breaking news
um they're just incredible thing ready
um and uh you know like we're we're not
like our brand isn't freestyle driven we
do freestyles yeah but it's not like you
know we do both you know what I mean
where I would say we're more known for
interviews you know of course yeah so
like
I gotta hit artist sometimes to be like
hey I know you come to La make sure you
got the other clip ready you know what I
mean like yeah save me something you
know what I mean but but y'all I feel
like now if people come to New York like
they're coming there to do your [__]
yeah I think you know even like because
Flex is a lot harder to get on to you
know what I mean like absolutely yeah so
like do you do you guys have those
conversations like hey look just just do
something man if you like it we'll use
it if not we'll scrap it like oh hell
yeah we definitely have those combos
like I also give artists like the
opportunity like look if you don't want
to do a freestyle like let's get a
performance video out of you yeah dude I
know you all do that like you did the
sexy red performance exactly yeah which
which is one of the funniest things we
ever shot too but like Anna Lee Choppa
did a performance with uh his Duda Gino
that's two times four times I'm sorry if
I say that wrong bro uh I'm sorry but
like he did a performance off the deluxe
off of uh Cottonwood too which is
totally cool because it still went crazy
regardless because at the end of the day
not a lot of people knew that song so a
lot of people in the comments like oh
this is a fire free satisfied even
though it's people don't know how to
read two by the way it's like it says
performance at the bottom but regardless
but I just try to get something out I'm
like look if you don't like it maybe
come do a lip sync of like a song that
you have on the project like like
something let's just do something you
know what I'm saying because I like
maximizing content like you're there
you're there for an hour it's like a 20
30 minute interview sometimes depending
how talkative you are and then you know
then if you do a lip sync it takes like
10 minutes not even to get that done
um but you know most people already know
like if but if I had a dollar bro for
like how many freestyles we haven't
released two or like you know haven't
come out like you know I'd be rich by
now what is don't tell me who did it but
what was the because we've had some very
long freestyle sessions where
[__] will take like 30 takes oh
yeah okay okay where it's like crazy
like I think there was like one time we
had someone who was in here for like an
hour and I literally was like look man I
got [__] to do so this is your final go
and they got it what was the longest you
had to wait for someone to nail their
[__] why are you laughing bro I hear you
in the back no I'm not gonna say no name
I'm not gonna don't say the name don't
say that yeah you know me I'm not gonna
do that but uh it was actually pretty it
was actually within the last six months
there was one that we stopped laughing
yo we was there the k a month ago maybe
I know it was more than a month ago we
were there at 9pm would you leave
I love the like 12. Jesus
she went though she's still working but
like so how about say that that's the
case you got to be like yo if we get
this right it's gonna do well for us
yeah no there's that you know that
happens a lot though it's like me and me
and Rob will like look at each other and
like I like you know we both have that
like look on our face we're like we want
to go home but like we both like are
like very well aware that's like look if
we get this done this [__] is gonna go
right and if they tell us they don't
want it out they're never coming back
you know what I'm saying like where we
sit spent three hours with your ass like
nah we've had that that's happened a lot
to us like where artists have like come
on and then they'll just be like they'll
do their [__] right and like let's say
we drop it like a month or two later
whatever it is right and then um they'll
be like oh I don't want I don't like
this anymore and then they're like I
want to come redo it I'm like
it was like a two hour long interview
and I I yeah I didn't like the way it
came off in that let me redo that a
two-hour long interview is Crazy by the
way for them to ask if we do it it's
someone that we're very close friends
with
it is bold
foreign
I can't wait for you to tell me after
but you let them you would you let
people come back after that or do you be
like nah don't come back no more Freddie
Gibbs what are my best friends oh it's
pretty good we did an interview and he
was like Hey maker we just redo the
whole interview and I was like bro did
you drop it I was like no we I had to
cut out so much and and I get it he was
in a weird place like and he just didn't
want certain [__] in there by the time
no it wasn't the one we was drunk okay
okay do you cut do you cut up your
interviews a lot like that I'll give a
like artist opportunity like you know
like you said like I don't want to like
make people uncomfortable coming over
here so if like there's an artist that
like comes on the show and they're like
hey I said this yeah can you take that
out I don't care like I'm not gonna be
like nah [__] that you know like the
only time that ever happened was
we had dropped a little pump interview
and
um
y'all chocolate tells me everything I
need to know about this interview yeah
well he tried to like his his little
weenie ass white boy manager I was like
bro you know where the [__] we at bro
come through if you want to talk that
crazy [__] like so what happened was the
interview goes up if they didn't like
the title because I put oh they never
liked the time they never like the
[__] time I put I put like little
pump on new music uh J Cole predicting
his fall off or no not I didn't say his
fall off his career
if if J Cole predicted his career or
something like that it wasn't even like
crazy like flavoring right but they
didn't like the fact J Cole was
mentioned in the in the title so I even
so they had hit me and then they had
like his other manager hit me who like
Works uh I forget what label she works
at but she works with Doug she works
with a lot of people she's like well
respected in the industry so I took it
out of the title right
and then then they had hit me and they
were like because we put the clip up
because we put Clips up right like yo
his guy hit me like yo you got to take
that [__] down and I was like or what
it's already up like what you mean I
gotta take it down tell me what's gonna
happen if I don't take it down bro like
what do you what the [__] are you gonna
do bro you see you come back to the
studio we're here all day you know what
I mean and
uh a little pump posted my phone number
on his story and said call me
my phone was blowing the [__] up for
like a whole night oh my God
oh my God yeah it was hilarious oh my
God so you're gonna change your number
obviously yeah yeah I mean I turned my I
just was like I have two phones right so
I just turned that one off
I was driving to Mexico at the time so I
just turned it off and I had all kind I
had all kinds of [__] like weird ass
like pasty white [__] from Germany
sending me nudes and [__] on WhatsApp
like it was [__] weird bro what the
hell it was super weird but you left the
interview up obviously like yeah it's on
there ready to go run it up yeah keep on
go keep watching that I guess right yeah
and it was like a fair interview to
little pump I was like giving them props
and [__] like I see I've watched some of
the clips too like it didn't even seem
like it was like it is what it is it was
funny though it wasn't like a messy
interview like it wasn't it was very
just a genuine conversation about where
he's at and like the whole but you know
what people are delusional people are
extremely delusional so it's like you
know if if he'd have shown some sort of
like humility and like like you know
self-awareness in that interview I feel
like people would be like oh a little
pump you know matured a little but he
was like
I'm rich when I was like did J Cole you
know looking back at y'all's interview
when y'all's interaction do you think he
predicted anything that ended up
happening with your career and she was
like I just know I'm rich and I was like
all right bro well yeah well J Cole J
Cole is also very rich shout out to J
Cole co-owner of the Hornets God damn it
literally co-owner of the Hornets now
that [__] is crazy to me I love that